mike alex congratulations you've made it
into the final round of this competition
which means that you're both one step
closer to the title of fortune fire
champion and a check for 10 grand all
you have to do now is recreate an iconic
weapon from history that weapon is
the horseman's axe
used by mounted knights and armies the
horseman's axe became the weapon of
choice after body armor made swords less
effective
the heavier axe with its concave blade
allowed horsemen to strike more
effective blows using a sweeping
overhead stroke that penetrated armor
early depictions of medieval warfare
shows the axe cleaving an opponent's
helmet delivering a fatal strike
in the film sleepy hollow the headless
horseman wields a horseman's axe
you're both talented bladesmiths show us
ten thousand dollar blades that you can
be proud of we'll see you in five days
good luck
luck good luck
my name is alex ruiz and i forge blades
on nights and weekends i used to make
hammers and tongs for bladesmiths and i
got bit by the bug describe myself in
three words
loves to forge
got this big block of 4140 it's a really
good impact steel
if anything's going to hold up to
hitting something it's going to be that
4140 head 4140 body i may have five days
but if the competition taught me
anything
work fast work diligently in case i run
into a last minute issue
getting that spread out another inch and
a half
to be past minimum is my biggest
challenge
i'm tugging these little nubs in hoping
that i can open them up this way i got
some with
this is not gonna become five and a half
or six inches i'm gonna have to start
over but i'm keeping the spike my plan
now is to cut it right here and i'm
gonna forge weld this to this
i'm happy i've got something that's
solid and it looks like an axe i got the
bell hook peened over now i need a heat
treat it's a tense moment i'm gonna heat
treat one section and the other heat
treat will make or break my edge
literally and figuratively
[Music]
now that the heat treats done i'm
testing my weapon on a piece of sheet
metal i want to see what kind of damage
it'll do
nothing loose
it will bend
my name is mike bailey there is a lot of
magic in bladesmithing metal came from
space this is the elements of the
universe
also i get to play with fire and hit
thanks i mean where else
my overall plan is to do a two-piece
head and then attach it separately to
the handle
the hardest part of this weapon is going
to be not being afraid to continue in
fear of making some mistake
i can't have analysis paralysis i can't
analyze the problem to the point where i
do nothing
quenching the shaft i used a torch
because i thought i'd have a difficult
time in the forge
i think it's hard
next i'm going to paint in the belt hook
the belt hook doesn't fit snugly like i
was hoping
the last thing i want to do is to weld
it because it's a hard material and the
extra heat from welding can make the
metal brittle i'm adding the sassafras
handle
it finishes beautifully it's soft it's
relatively easy to work with the
handle's complete then i'm going to
start hacking my forest now
i'm scared to test it but i have to to
see how it's going to hold up
goes right through it
i'd kind of like to keep it around i
think it'd be real handy around here
placements this is the kill test the
horseman's axe it's actually two weapons
in one it's got an edge that can last or
we can chop and a spike that can
penetrate and crush bones to see what
kind of lethal damage your axe will do
i will take your horseman sacks and
deliver lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy
mike you're up first you ready yes i am
as you can see i'm recovering from an
injury so one of my students will have
the satisfaction of testing your weapon
it's a tendency
well mike let's talk about your weapon
your edge over here is sharp it
lacerated
deep into the bowels right here your
spike definitely caved in all the way
into the chest and straight into the
heart the only issue we have is that
your handle is a little bit on the
rounded side so there is a tendency to
slightly roll but overall your weapon
will kill thank you
alex you're up next you ready yes
let's do this all right i'm pretty proud
of what i created it's just a little
heavy and that's a big of a concern
going in
sweet
alex your weapon here is a little bit on
the heavy side
but you know what it is well balanced
the edge of your blade here cut deep in
the chest cavity and it broke the bones
your spike here right into the heart and
of course on the swing it pretty much
just disemboweled the dummy right there
your weapon
will kill yes thank you
next up is the strength test jake
now we know ice can be very brutal on an
edge so i'm going to take your
horseman's axes and repeatedly strike
into these large blocks of ice to see
how well they hold up mike you're up
first you ready yes i am
oh well mike unfortunately we had a
serious failure on your axe
with this weld point in the junction of
the belt hook
alex
you still have to pass this test are you
ready yes i'm ready
there's only one thing standing between
me and a ten thousand dollar check
and it's really big and it's made of ice
[Music]
[Music]
uh alex your horseman's axe did quite a
job on that ice
everything's still tight
your edge is still razor sharp thank you
so all in all very nicely done
bladesmiths our weapons tests here are
designed to be exceptionally brutal in
order to set your weapons apart from one
another
mike
your blade did not survive our strength
test for that reason i have to ask you
to please leave the forge okay
i am disappointed but when i go home i'm
gonna have a smile on my face
forged in fire has risen me from the
dead somehow
i will take this forward with me for the
rest of my life
alex congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
[Applause]
it's surreal it's really surreal well
come on over here and shake our hands oh
wow
i can't really fathom like i've won like
i i won definitely tops everything else
i've ever done
being the fortune fire champion just
shows i've applied what i've always
tried to teach others never stop
learning
you